this problem says some people use the
letters foi l or foil as a strategy for
making sure they have multiplied all the
terms use the foil approach to multiply
3x plus 2 times 5x minus 7 I'm going to
say you tell it let you know just from
the get-go I personally don't like foil
because it's kind of just it's a
mnemonic to kind of memorize steps and
you really don't know what you're doing
but since this problem says use foil
I guess we'll use oil so let's just use
foil so foil stands for foil stands for
that's why I hate these mnemonics
because as soon as you're done with the
test you're going to forget this and
when you're 30 years old you're not
going to even remember what foil stands
for especially how do we apply it but it
stands for first outside outside inside
inside and last and the whole point of
it is to make sure that you multiply
every term in this first expression with
every other term in the last expression
now the reason why you're doing it is
you're really just doing the
distributive property twice and I'll do
that later in this video because I
really dislike just memorizing foil but
since we have it written there let's do
it so first says let's multiply the two
first terms so first let me do it in
different colors the first terms two
first terms was a 3x and a 5x so you
multiply the 3x times the 5x then the
outside says multiply the outside
numbers so multiply the 3x and the
negative seven so notice we multiply the
3x times the 5x and now we're going to
multiply the 3x times the negative 7 so
plus 3x times negative 7 that's the
outside then it tells you to do the
inside so we'll do the inside numbers or
the 2 and the 5 X so plus 2 times 5x and
then L stands for last or the last
numbers or 2 times negative 7 plus 2
times negative 7 now we just have to
simplify 3x times 5x is 15 x squared
plus 3x times negative 7 is negative 21
X 2 times 5x is 10x
can X and then you have 2 times negative
7 is negative 14 negative 14 and now we
can combine these middle two terms right
here if I have negative 21 X and then
I'm adding 10x to that that makes me
back to negative 11x so this is negative
11x and we have the 15 x squared out
front 15 x squared minus 11x minus 14
which is this which is the the product
of these two expressions so foil does
give you the right answer but it's just
not always obvious why you're doing all
of these different combinations of
multiplications but this is the right
answer but what I want to do is take a
side here to just show you that as long
as you just knew the distributive
property you could have done this
problem you did not have to know foil
and this way you'll never forget it so
if I'm going to multiply 3x plus 2 x
times 5x minus 7 what you can think
about is this is just some some number
here and if I'm multiplying it times
this expression I can just distribute it
on to this expression if this was just a
I don't know if this was just a 2 we
would say okay this is same thing as 2
times 5x plus 2 times negative 7 that's
what the distributive property is so
let's just distribute it out let's just
distribute we have to just multiply this
whole thing multiply this whole thing
times each of those terms that's just
the distributive property so you get 3x
plus 2 times 5x times 5x I could write
the 5x out front here so that's just
that times that and then you're going to
have plus 3x plus 2 and then you have 3x
plus 2 times the second term times
negative 7 I could just put a negative
plus here at a negative 7 or I could say
it's negative 7 times 3x plus 2 so it's
5x times 3x plus 2 minus 7 times 3x plus
2 this was just the distributive
property now again we can apply the
distributive property to get the 5x
times each of these terms so this is
going to be 5x times 3x times 3x plus 5x
times 2 plus 5x
times two just doing the distributive
property on this now we do it again here
so that we have minus 7 or negative 7
times 3x so minus 7 times 3x times 3x
and then negative 7 times 2 so minus 7
times 2 and what do we get
scroll down a little bit I'll do these
in a neutral color we get 5x times 3x is
15 x squared 5x times 2 is 10 X 7 times
3x is minus 21x and then negative 7
times 2 is minus 14 and just like we saw
up here just like we saw up here these
two terms can be merged into 10 X minus
21 X is negative 11x so we get 15 x
squared minus 11x minus 14 get it done
it just doing the distributive property
twice which you're less likely to forget
when you're 30 years old or if you like
you can memorize foil